so good afternoon I am Betsy Humphries
deputy director of the National Library
of Medicine and on behalf of the
fabulous multidisciplinary staff of the
National Library of Medicine and the
Friends of the National Library of
Medicine I'm welcome to all of you we
are really both those of you who are in
the room and we think we have a lot of
people watching us the videocast across
the country maybe around the world as
well so we are delighted however that so
many distinguished guests have traveled
here to be with us some over long
distances and I would like to extend our
special welcome to Louis flatly and a
number of Patty's sisters brothers and
other relatives who are able to come
with us we're particularly delighted to
have them here I think that NLM is very
rich in its advisors partners and
supporters and I'm going to acknowledge
just a few of them who are here with us
today
I can't possibly acknowledge all of you
but first Bob greenness who is chair at
the NLM Board of Regents we have a
number of other regions both present and
former with us today which is great we
have barbara redmond president and glen
campbell chair of the board of the
Friends of NLM and a number of other
friends friends and in the room we have
Teresa not president and Kevin Balio
Chien executive director of the Medical
Library Association and a number of
other leaders and partners and
supporters including in our national
network of libraries of medicine here
today so thank you all for being here
and I believe we have Doug Fritz mo who
is the president and CEO of the American
Medical Informatics Association NLM has
not only many partners around the world
and out in the field but we have a lot
of great partners across federal
agencies and of course here within the
NIH and we're very glad that I think
Susannah Fox who is the chief technology
the officer of the HHS is here and I
think perhaps also we have John White
who is the deputy national coordinator
of the National deputy national
coordinator of health information
technology and from right here at NIH
Gary Gibbons who is the director of
NHLBI and Pat Grady who is the director
of the National Institute of Nursing
Research and I have to say within here
we really welcome the very large number
of nursing leaders from across the
country who are with us today thank you
all for being here so and we have
Francis Collins the director of NIH
[Music]
so today is definitely a day for looking
to the future but I'm going to take a
few minutes to set the stage by
reviewing some historical milestones
that have brought NLM to its current
position when the within the world of
biomedical and health information and
data as it happens 2016 is the 100th and
80th anniversary of the establishment of
NLM's earliest predecessor library
within the office of the Surgeon General
of the army and 2016 is also the 60th
anniversary of the passage of the
National Library of Medicine Act which
in 1956 transferred the Armed Forces
medical library from the Department of
Defense into what was then the
Department of Health Education and
Welfare and in addition to renaming the
library this Act which was co-sponsored
by Senators Lister Hill you're here
today and John F Kennedy gave NLM it's
great mission and I'm going to read this
to you quote to assist the advancement
of the medical and related scientists
sciences and to aid the dissemination
and exchange of scientific and other
information important to the progress of
medicine and to the public health end
quote
let me hasten to add for this audience
that the act explicitly defined medicine
and medical to include preventive and
therapeutic medicine dentistry pharmacy
hospitalization nursing public health
and the fundamental sciences related
thereto and other related fields of
study research or activity in addition
to enumerate the basic NLM functions
that support permanent access to the
world's biomedical literature the law
also requires the library quote to
engage in such other activities as the
secretary determines appropriate so in
the 1960s the scope of NLM was radically
expanded by both the Congress and the
secretary
in terms of adding grant Authority
creating our first intramural research
division the Lister Hill National Center
for biomedical communication
specifically in joining us to create a
toxicology information program
transferring the Public Health Service
audio-visual facility to the National
Library of Medicine from the CDC and I
could go on the the scope of what we do
and particularly the addition of our
grant program in 1965 in our and the
requirement to create the national
network of libraries of medicine just
radically expanded what the library did
and set the stage the programs that came
out of those expansions set the stage
for the next big set of expansions which
began in 1988 with the legislation that
created the National Center for
Biotechnology information within NLM
acts which also expanded our activities
in health services research general
assignments to the government but also
to NLM in terms of clinical trials
registration and to the NIH in terms of
public access I think that I always say
that February 2000 was one of the great
months in the history of NLM because it
was the month that both PubMed Central
our public access to our to our public
archive of articles in the in
biomedicine but also clinical trials.gov
debuted that that same month so I think
that we later were assigned
responsibilities by secretaries in areas
related to health data standards and
Health Services Research and we have
arrived today with a very wide-ranging
set of activities that affect virtually
all aspects of biomedical information
and health data in some way shape or
form and patty comes to us now
as the 19th person the first nurse and
the first woman to officially be
appointed as the library's director the
first appointed director was actually
John Shaw Billings before that there
wasn't a director he was appointed in
1865 and as many of you know he was then
actually purposely transformed the
library of the surgeon general's office
into a national medical library he
established the index Medicus and other
cataloguing and indexing things that are
a precursor of PubMed today he was also
involved in greatly expanding the
collection so when he left we were the
largest medical library in the world as
we still are today and established many
of our nationwide services so Patti if
we move forward to the modern area era
is just the fourth person to serve as
the director of the library since it has
been named the National Library of
Medicine and I have had the distinct
pleasure and privilege of knowing all of
these great leaders and working for and
with three of them now including Patti
in my view they all represent exactly
the right choice at the right time in
the case of Patti's three predecessors
each prepared the way for the next
person in essence transforming the
National Library of Medicine and it's
directorship into a job that would
appeal to the next person we are all
fortunate that Donlan Berg's expansion
of NLM programs and scientific data
electronic health records public health
services to patients and the public have
made this job attractive to Patti
Brennan so it is my great pleasure to
introduce Patricia Flight Flatley
Brennan to present her first public
remarks as the director of the National
Library of Medicine
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I feel very welcomed and I want to
thank you all for giving up this finely
beautiful set afternoon in Washington DC
to come inside
I'm delighted honored and just
absolutely gratified to be standing here
as the fourth director of the National
Library of Medicine in a line of 19
important leaders but none has been more
important than Betsy Humphreys who took
the responsibility for a 16-month period
to transition to consider to continue to
accelerate to bring the library to a
place that it needs to be and I thank
her so much for her work
[Applause]
[Music]
I also want to thank the audiovisual
program development branch and the
communications team for this tremendous
afternoon it's going to be a great time
they've worked very hard and they've
spent an awful lot of time preparing
materials to help you understand what I
am now learning about I've been here
three weeks I think it's appropriate to
start a little bit to introduce myself
to you some of you I know many I'm
starting to get to know and some I've
lived with for quite a while I am a
mother of Connor up here I am a daughter
of Lois and Tom I'm a sister to my
siblings and a friend and colleague I
hope and trust to my friends those here
present and those around the world that
I've had the privilege of working with I
for the past 30 years I have blended two
professions nursing and Industrial
Engineering in the service of people
living at home learning to take care of
themselves coping with complex problems
nursing brings to this challenge a
fundamental unique focus on the person
on the diagnosis and treatment of human
response to disease development or
disability we are concerned about the
response to fundamental pathologies and
trauma we bring something no one else
brings industrial engineers bring a
focus on technological solutions to
complex problems so what a great mix
this was now my focus has been primarily
on reaching into the home which is not a
place you usually see industrial
engineers and the challenge of reaching
into the home brings us into a place
that's intimate private unstructured and
the place where most health occurs we
spent a lot of our time visiting homes
we've been in over a thousand homes in
Wisconsin alone and we learned many
things from that but fundamentally we
learned that people don't like engineers
and nurses traipsing through their
bedrooms so we had to find a better way
to bring our understanding on our
solutions to those in need we developed
through their techniques of virtual
reality and 3d rendering the opportunity
to recreate households as point clouds
and then study them in depth in virtual
reality caves and then
began to learn things such as half
occurs all over the house that little
pill box that you carry with you
actually has to fit in your pocket it
doesn't do any good if it just sits on
the counter and in fact sometimes health
occurs in the middle of the night when
people feel the most private so as we
build tools and technology to deliver
information into people's hands as they
need it we have to think about where
they are but thinking about where they
are and thinking about the home leaves
me to have to tell you a little bit more
about my family for a few minutes it's
quite a family story maybe a myth that
the seventh son of the seventh son will
be king of Ireland no our dear dad was
the seventh son in a large Irish
Catholic family and he met our lovely
mother and they looked forward to
starting on the dynasty
um they began and first there was Jean
he'll meet these people to SAFTA and
most of them are here first there was
Jean and then there was me and then
Kathleen this was not looking very good
but then our brother Kevin came along in
our brother Tim and hope hub returned to
the family and then all of a sudden
Eileen but then Brian and then Shawn and
then Tom things are looking better but
then Bridget and then that's what we had
so there were 10 of us and there is no
king of Ireland
so I'm here to say well what exactly is
there for the second daughter of the
seventh son and it is the opportunity at
this point in my career at this point in
our lives at this point in society to
work with this amazing group of 1700
professionals and colleagues and
employers and librarians and patients
around the world to bring information to
the point of health and information to
the point of need so in my remarks today
I'm going to do three things
we'll be drawing from our history we'll
be doing a lot of celebrating of our
present and I'm going to ask you to work
with me some to anticipate our future
Betsy remarked of the importance of John
Shaw Billings to us who brought the idea
that information came from the past and
yet comes into the present to be have
the library be a dynamic interplay of
medicine and information so that in the
year 2000 Don limber could create
network around the world that anywhere
where people were there was electronic
access to the information needed for
medicine some of those who helped shape
this program are in this room right now
and I'm grateful for what you did one of
those is leaving next week to go back to
Africa we are continuing to focus the
resources of the National Library of
Medicine around the world recognizing
that we draw from our past and it
becomes a vibrant present for us the
goal is to make sure information is
available everywhere and assure that
that information is meaningful and
useful at the point of need so let's
take a look at some of the things we've
been doing the National Library of
Medicine is first and foremost has as
its vision to support discovery our
vision is to Dysport support discovery
and we do this in two primary ways the
first way is to examine explore and
cultivate and expand the basic
biomedical information sciences and
library sciences to make sure that the
tools needed for you to be able to take
care of yourself bring information that
is actionable meaningful understandable
useful to everyone but we also provide
the knowledge platform for biomedical
science discoveries we accelerate the
ability of its talented and smart
investigators to understand their
phenomenon to communicate it to others
and to learn and to realize in faster
and faster ways right now we run a
research and training program in our
extramural area and I'd like to focus on
two candidates from each of those areas
to tell you about what we actually do
Emily Mallory is a graduate student a
PhD student at Stanford University her
work is to study large-scale extraction
of gene interactions from the full-text
literature using deep dive of a natural
language processing tool there's lots
and lots of information out there it's
growing too quickly for human minds to
read so Emily's work is going to help us
extract from the literature these
interactions and categorize them and
make them accessible for other work
workers just an hour who is at Rice
University is
trying to improve drug safety by using
data mining techniques to mine the vast
literature we have a tenement NLM to
first discover interactions no one can
read all of the articles we have here
Nerys work is trying to help us have
glean from information from there using
some of our text processing and
representation tools to be able to make
this information accessible to machine
learning algorithm so he's not simply
going through and cultivating did
researcher a find it was find result B
but he's going through and trying to map
how often certain patterns emerged what
were precursors and how we can better
understand them these are our young
people are pre doc and postdoc trainees
and we're very proud of them we have 14
programs around the country to train
production postdocs in addition we have
we run a range of extramural programs
both research and extension I'm going to
point out two of our researchers Scott
Mauer who is a new investigator has an
award where is it Arizona State
University by the way in Tempe he's
looking to merge viral genetics and
climate and population data to be able
to understand human animal or zoonotic
zoonotic disease and genetic
surveillance so he's trying to unbreak
together ideas about how the climate
around you the experience that you have
and the population is that you're living
with can make or influence your ability
to be susceptible to diseases in
addition Elizabeth 10 at Brown
University
she's right looking through the
electronic health record trying to
better understand family linkages as we
learn about her edible diseases and also
as we learn about the adult health
effects of childhood exposures
understanding a person not as a point in
time but as a life flow is essential and
our investigators are building the tools
that allow us to do this and again I'm
extremely proud of them we also though
in addition to building tools we reach
in an archive and present history to the
world our history of Medicine Division
recently presented a program as an
installation called confronting violence
what's important about this program
isn't only that we understood aspects
that contributed to the understanding of
violence but
all health professionals developed
policies and procedures that enabled
them to manage to understand to detect
violence in a person they needed to
bring together what we would call the
grey literature meeting notes from
hospital meetings small guidelines from
institutions as they began to understand
and confront this problem which we now
know broadly is it's an intimate partner
violence without aspects without
explorations like that we would not
first of all be able to call the
public's attention in a meaningful way
to how knowledge builds but more
importantly we would not be able to
document how knowledge builds this is
critical for us the National Library of
Medicine accelerates and plays a
critical role in shaping the federal
policy on open science we developed the
first model open access strategy that
has now been adopted by many federal
agencies in which the research findings
built on federal funds your tax dollars
are made available quickly and broadly
and without restriction to the general
public we have also worked to make sure
that their vast resources of the
National Library of Medicine are
available through open api's open
application programming interfaces so
that others who want to build tools upon
our work are able to do that so we
export not only access to the knowledge
but tools to help use the knowledge this
is a great thing recently we've begun to
take up the federal challenge as the
federal season the federal government's
America creates charge to create
challenges the National Library of
Medicine image recognition challenge was
a way to engage citizens in science
public data available for scientists and
laypeople to improve patient safety and
the basic question that was asked was
can your cell phone tell what pill that
is this could be useful can a cell phone
tell what pill it is can help an
individual family member in the middle
of the night trying to understand what
was that pill that my kid swallowed
what's going on with me what do I need
to do and our first Prize winner came
from a team of students at Michigan
State University
they were able given a training set of
7,000 images and 1,000 testing images to
identify
75% of the pills accurately what we're
learning is how to take emerging
technologies cellphone simple smartphone
technologies and use that to help people
better their own health at a point where
they need to be and where we need to
support them we are also trying to
improve healthcare we ultimately do not
give care but our standards of
terminologies are human factors
understanding of teams our delivery of
disaster information in the moment all
allow us to ensure that the information
needed by health professionals at the
point of care is available there and
secondarily that that information flows
into a larger and more complete
understanding of all of the kinds of
practice based interventions that lead
to an improvement in the health of our
populations watch with me for a moment
while we celebrate our present in the
work going on here at the National
Library of Medicine
[Music]
this is a great place to work the
accomplishments of the colleagues and
the directors and the managers and the
staff that have gone before me provide a
basis for us to know that we can develop
the resources needed to help meet the
challenges of the world I want you to
anticipate with me for a few minutes
what the future may hold for the health
of the population for the health of your
family for yourself it's important for
us of the National Library of Medicine
to think about what challenges lie ahead
in healthcare because we need to be
ready with the information resources and
supports needed to either help discover
and characterize them or to sufficiently
bring information to be able to assist
with them now you all each have your own
three or four top health care concerns
at the moment and if you don't I ask you
to take a minute right now to think of
them because they are what drives us to
create the information tools to be
responsive I'd like to call three to
your attention first the genetic
discoveries of the last 20 years have
heralded a promise of precision medicine
that now may be realized so we may know
not to give you coding because you lack
the gene that converts the enzyme that
makes the coding I need
pharmacologically accessible to you or
it may be better to treat you with a
certain approach to your cancer than
what was originally thought based on
your symptoms ology but it also requires
us that we help every person understand
this complex twisty genome inside of
them and ways to do that and that reach
across the literacy lines that reach
into the everyday schools of children
that reach to my mom are part of our
purview second infectious disease
remains hugely problematic and what
we're learning more because of our work
here at the National Library of Medicine
is that mutations occur quickly and
differentially across the world
understanding how those mutations are
occurring when to anticipate where they
might be emerging will allow clinicians
to better respond to them and finally we
must mention chronic diseases
asthma diabetes hypertension there they
continue unabated and they're in some
ways growing and while I have been a
part of the community that has said let
the patients participate for they will
help us I also recognize the good
intentions is not enough powerful
information effective information tools
good surveillance are also necessary so
infectious diseases
excuse me sir chronic disease management
which will be remain a partnership
between professionals and patients has a
third leg of that stool that I think of
as the National Library of Medicine as
we think towards how we will help what
will we do the National Library of
Medicine has certain things we can do
and certain things we can't do I'm going
to bring forward three challenges that I
hope we'll be able to do we don't do
surgery upstairs and we have no blood
banks here but we can begin to take a
lifespan and a life flow approach to
understanding complex chronic diseases
to understand the consequences in adult
health of childhood exposures and begin
to think of health not as a moment in
time but there's a process across time
that requires us to rethink how we index
that requires us to understand
sequential and versioning activities
information as an interaction not as a
delivery mechanism second we need to we
can support the creation of a learning
health system the better leverage data
to better foster effective health care
we can do this by improving the
dissemination and use of standard ways
of expressing health care problems of
assuring that your headache in New York
is described in the same way as your
headache in California but more
importantly as the computational models
that underlie that are available and
accessible and can be applied to
information and finally I believe most
that we can continue as a library to do
what we've done we've started over the
years which is enabling improved
treatment and better self management by
harnessing technologies we are not the
National Heart Lung and Blood Institute
we're not going to understand and
discover the basic physiology but we
will be able to provide tools for
understanding for
accelerating that understanding and for
people to take action on them so now
walk with me as we anticipate our future
a little bit
what should the National Library of
Medicine do well one of the things I've
learned in the first three weeks that
I've been here is that the director
doesn't have a whole lot of say over
this but the director can shine a
spotlight and and and provide a little
direction and sometimes nudge with a
little money and that's where I will be
spending my next few years but remember
first and foremost the National Library
of Medicine is about discovery and
discovery in two planes one is
supporting the biomedical sciences
discoveries and secondarily to
understanding basic biomedical
informatics discoveries we need better
natural language processing tools we
need the ability to have
privacy-preserving algorithms to run our
data on we have the possibility to
assist in the development of information
making it accessible to the millions and
millions of people that reach us every
week and the millions and millions more
computers that seem to be talking to our
computers without any human
intermediaries our investigators who
specialized in image analysis and
exploration and a natural language
processing are building new tools that
we can now search on a squiggle we can
investigate and look for shapes rather
than looking for words this brings us
great promise it would be inappropriate
and unresponsible to not address the
importance of standards as we go into
the next period of our work here
standards powerful way of making sure
that information flows freely without
information flowing freely words can
flow freely but they can't be processed
or understood so to make knowledge flow
freely
we need structured ways to represent it
bibliographic standards tell us how to
represent library catalogs information
standards tell us how to represent how
to understand that the experience of a
person know where and never before has
it been more important to have attention
and systematic approaches to standards
and my colleagues who are in the
audience or listening country why
probably never expected to hear me say
that
but standards are essential to the
future why because the amount of
information that's coming at us is
flowing way too fast
and standards are one way to organize
not the only but one way and we must
continue to invest in these now allowing
the genomic scientists to use an
electronic health record to understand
the phenotype is only going to happen if
those records are accessible in a way
that the genomic science on scientists
understands them so standards are us now
partnering is really critical for the
National Library of medicines future we
are just like BSF BASF rather we don't
make the information we make it
accessible useful safe stored available
and curated our responsibility is to
make sure that what scientists need or
clinicians want or patients look for can
be gotten without a lot of barriers
without a lot of costs and with with a
great deal of trust the imprimatur of
trust of our National Library of
Medicine allows our partnering scientist
to be sure that what we deliver them is
accurate is Korea is correct and current
we must remember that this is a job that
only the National Library of Medicine
can do and we do it really well we have
to continue to do this the future is a
future of data the data will come from
all sorts of places right now we're most
familiar with cellular molecular data
genomic data and symptoms but there's
new data elements out there even now
that tell us about the health of people
that give us a chance to ensure that we
can get into their hands and to
understand from their experience what's
going on sound of a baby crying or a
family having an argument the motion of
a person walking after surgery these are
all data types that we've only just
begun to explore and are working image
technologies has got to expand to help
us understand the fluid mode
so good afternoon I am Betsy Humphries
deputy director of the National Library
of Medicine and on behalf of the
fabulous multidisciplinary staff of the
National Library of Medicine and the
Friends of the National Library of
Medicine I'm welcome to all of you we
are really both those of you who are in
the room and we think we have a lot of
people watching us the videocast across
the country maybe around the world as
well so we are delighted however that so
many distinguished guests have traveled
here to be with us some over long
distances and I would like to extend our
special welcome to Louis flatly and a
number of Patty's sisters brothers and
other relatives who were able to come
with us we're particularly delighted to
have them here
so good afternoon I am Betsy Humphreys
deputy director of the National Library
of Medicine and on behalf of the
fabulous multidisciplinary staff of the
National Library of Medicine and the
Friends of the National Library of
Medicine I'm welcome to all of you we
are really both those of you who are in
the room and we think we have a lot of
people watching us the videocast across
the country maybe around the world as
well so we are delighted however that so
many distinguished guests have traveled
so good afternoon I am Betsy Humphries
deputy director of the National Library
of Medicine and on behalf of the
fabulous multidisciplinary staff of the
National Library of Medicine and the
Friends of the National Library of
Medicine I'm welcome to all of you we
are really both those of you who are in
the room and we think we have a lot of
people watching us the videocast across
the country maybe around the world as
well so we are delighted however that so
many distinguished guests have traveled
here to be with us some over long
distances and I would like to extend our
special welcome to Louis flatly and a
number of Patty's sisters brothers and
other relatives who were able to come
with us we're particularly delighted to
have them here I think that NLM is very
rich in its advisors partners and
supporters and I'm going to acknowledge
just a few of them who are here with us
today
I can't possibly acknowledge all of you
but first Bob greenness who is chair at
the NLM Board of Regents we have a
number of other regions both present and
former with us today which is great we
have barbara redmond president and glen
campbell chair of the board of the
Friends of NLM and a number of other
friends friends and in the room we have
Teresa not president and Kevin Bally
oathean
executive director of the Medical
Library Association and a number of
other leaders and partners and
supporters including in our national
network of libraries of medicine here
today so thank you all for being here
and I believe we have Doug Fritz Moe who
is the president and CEO of the American
Medical Informatics Association NLM has
not only many partners around the world
and out in the field but we have a lot
of great partners across federal
agencies and of course here within the
NIH and we're very glad that I think
Susannah Fox who is the chief technology
officer of the HHS is here
I think perhaps also we have John White
who is the deputy national coordinator
of the National deputy national
coordinator of health information
technology and from right here at NIH
Gary Gibbons who is the director of
NHLBI and Pat Grady who is the director
of the National Institute of Nursing
Research and I have to say within here
we really welcome the very large number
of nurses essence will be complemented
by listening sessions to the challenges
the NLM's response to those challenges
and those listening sessions will
involve the NIH as a community will
involve the involve the biomedical
informatics and library science
communities our primary stakeholders and
the population at large it's a lot of
people to reach and we're going to look
for a lot of support with this and
finally we're going to be evaluating our
physical plant because yes our computers
are great and our books are beautiful
and there's many treasures but sometimes
our stairways are dark and sometimes our
rooms leak and we need to attend to that
so we will be complementing a visioning
of the future a functional audit of our
current activities with an understanding
of what is needed to make sure that the
National Library of Medicine remains the
jewel in the crown of the NIH I thank
you for this opportunity and I trust
you'll keep in touch and work along with
me and my colleagues as we make this
happen thank you
[Applause]
I'm sure that you all can understand why
I was terribly enthused when I heard
that patty would be our next director
and I've become more enthused with every
each passing day that she's been here
for the last three weeks so it's been
great now it is my pleasure to introduce
the director of the National Institutes
of Health Francis Collins
he has many achievements and he's done
many great things and as I think you can
all tell one of the greatest things he's
done recently is appoint patty Brennan
as director of NLM
[Applause]
well I agree with that
patty wonderful remarks inspirational
walking us through where we've been
where we are now and especially where we
are going and I think we all share the
excitement that you have conveyed and
we're on your team and want to make this
dream turn into something really
spectacular and you're just the right
leader to make that happen I also really
want to say thank you to Betsy Humphries
for her wonderful leadership over these
16 months
keeping the NLM on a very remarkable
course and all the things you've done
for NLM before that as you outlined all
of these many other folks you've worked
with here and the leadership you have
shown you have been a wonderful
dedicated public servant and you have
made this place really wonderful so
thank you for that let's see
I often say that NLM is NIH is window to
the world this is an absolutely critical
part of everything we do most of those
people out there in this country and in
other countries who knows something
about NIH and seek information from NIH
they come in through this portal and
this portal has been remarkably well
designed to serve those needs and yet
the challenges are growing almost by the
hour maybe we shouldn't be in here
spending time we should be out there
figuring out how to make it and land
better but we'll get there and you have
the right leader to make that happen so
we can stop for a little bit and
celebrate what's been accomplished and
think hard about where this needs to go
next with this new leader this is a
great day I think for NIH to have the
opportunity here that I will in a moment
of swearing-in dr. patty Brennan as the
next director you can hear from her
vision that she's already on the path to
thinking about doing great things here
no one knows better than I the challenge
of trying to find leaders to come and be
part of our senior visionary group at
NIH and no one knows better than I what
a challenge it is for an organization
like NLM to find the right person with
the right skill set given the broad
diversity of what this institution has
on its list of responsibilities so the
task was daunting how could we find in a
single person the many talents and
abilities needed to lay the groundwork
for what you've just heard about NLM's
third essentially but when we found
patty Brennan I'm proud to say we found
the entire package she brings with her
this incredible extent of experiences
and that includes having cared for
patients as a practicing nurse but she's
got the tech side covered here extremely
well to that industrial engineer
attitude but brought to a very
interesting place as you have heard
improving the lives of homebound patient
by developing innovative in information
systems and services and picking the
opportunity to utilize cutting-edge
efforts in visualization and virtual
reality now to add to that body of data
so putting all those skills together I
believe makes her ideally suited to lead
the NLM in the era of precision medicine
where we are increasingly trying to
figure out how can science get together
with this desire to empower individuals
to be able to experience a better health
span as well as a better lifespan and
the library is going to become more than
ever the epicenter for biomedical data
science which is going to be the
foundation of everything we try to do in
precision medicine and so there could
hardly be a more important moment to
have the right leader and you can tell
from you what you've heard this
afternoon that we were very fortunate
indeed to recruit patty Brennan if that
weren't enough in terms of the skill
sets and their resumes I'm also able to
testify that patty is a wonderful human
being
we've just had a great example of her
communication skills she's also a lively
presence on Twitter and is about to
launch a blog had to talk about NLM but
I have found in the brief time that I've
been able to share ideas and talk about
sometimes challenging problems with
patty that her ability to sift through
those issues and to come across with a
view that is both nuanced and optimistic
is exactly what we need and so many of
these rooms where we're wrestling with
these issues so I think now that my
Twitter feed is coming out rather nicely
now with my 64,000 followers I might
have a run for my money here somebody
who really knows how to communicate I'll
see how that all goes so again without
further ado because I know there's a
reception and probably all of you would
like to have a chance to extend your
congratulations and we also want to hear
in a moment
from the chair of the Board of Regents
but we have a special moment now which
is the swearing in the oath of office
which I'm about to ask dr. Brennan to
read is a historical document it is the
same oath of office that is spoken by
every member of Congress when they come
after just being elected or re-elected
it's the same oath of office that is
recited by the vice president by the
members of the cabinet by judges
although judges have another oath they
have to do as well they have double oath
requirements and all of us who have been
at NIH have read this same oath
some of us twice for different positions
so you're connected in this way
through a long tradition by the way the
president's oath is a little different
maybe that explains why the Supreme
Court justice stumbled over it a couple
of years ago we won't go back to that
but of the oath that Patti's being asked
to read has been the one that has held
us all together and it's a solemn moment
a moment that someone like dr. Brennan
with all of her skills and all of her
talents and all of her contributions
stating her desire to be a public
servant to the people of the United
States and to defend the Constitution it
is I think something we will all kind of
be touched by and remember and we're
particularly fortunate here that dr.
Brennan's sister Jean flatly McGuire is
going to join us up here and hold a copy
of the Constitution which if you read
the program is a special one as the oath
is administered so patty can I ask you
to come up and Jean flattening acquire
also well I might have to rearrange
there I tried already
here I want you in the middle there you
go there you go and I'll be here alright
we have the right my brother clearly we
did not rehearse this okay and there is
this wonderful Constitution and what I'm
going to do is ask you to repeat after
me and I will go through relatively few
words at a time because otherwise it's
easy for both of us to get mixed up so
may I ask you to put your left hand on
the Constitution and to raise your right
hand and repeat after me
I state your name i patricia flatly
brennan do solemnly swear do solemnly
swear that I will support and defend
that I will support and defend the
Constitution of the United States
against all enemies against all enemies
foreign and domestic foreign and
domestic that I will bear true faith and
I will bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
and allegiance to the same that I take
this obligation freely then I take this
obligation freely without any mental
reservation without any mental
reservation or purpose of evasion or
purpose of evasion and that I will well
and faithfully and that I will well and
faithfully discharge the duties of the
office discharge the duties of the
office on which I am about to enter
on which I am about to enter so help me
God so help me God
congratulations thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and now I'll introduce the chairman of
the Board of Regents of the National
Library of Medicine dr. Robert greenness
and he will have the last few words well
there's a very tough act to follow and
I'm standing between you and
refreshments so I'll be very brief but I
am representing the Board of Regents and
the on behalf of the board I want to
extend our enthusiastic welcome to Patty
as the director of the National Library
of Medicine this really couldn't happen
at a more important time I think we
talked about the learning health system
and we're facing a number of challenges
political financial social and
technological and trying to make that
happen and the library is a uniquely
positioned to capitalize on marshalling
the science that's coming out of NIH and
elsewhere sharing the knowledge and
making it available and interoperable in
order to pull together this very complex
multifaceted health system and
healthcare system that we have in this
country and in the world so recognizing
the importance of playing a leading role
in shepherding this complex process then
that the Board of Regents is working
with patty as patty mentioned to launch
a new strategic planning initiative and
to engage the broad community of
stakeholders in this process so we're
very excited and I'm personally excited
to be chair at this point in time of the
board as this process unfolds and with a
new leader like patty to help us to
think through this and to implement our
vision
I wanted to just add a couple of
personal notes I think I've known patty
for some 28 years I actually looked up I
think we were both invited to give a
talk at Salt Lake City 28 years ago and
that's when I got to know her first and
since then we've had the privilege of
getting to know each other through
multiple committees joint working
sessions of various
things we've had brainstorming sessions
in some of our national meetings and
we've also shared some postdoc and
student and faculty to your faculty
mentees that we've come mentored and
what I've learned over this time and
continue to be impressed by is Patty's
insights her broad perspective her
organizational skills and ability to cut
to the chase
and I think we've seen all this and also
her leadership so the NLM I am confident
is in excellent hands as we embark on
this exciting future again our
congratulations and warmest welcome to
Patty and then I would like to just
close with letting you know that the
reception awaits where you will have a
chance to talk with Patty and wish her
well and also rekt inquire about the
next steps and I want to mention that
the reception food and refreshments are
provided by the Friends of the National
Library of Medicine so thank you
[Applause]